i'm shannon breme i'm bill hemmer i'm
kennedy and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday february 2nd 2022
i'm dave anthony
republicans say the year-long surge of
migrants coming here illegally has
border agent morale at an all-time low
it's exceptionally frustrating for law
enforcement saying why am i putting my
life on the line every day to be able to
do this when everybody's just being
allowed to be able to come into the
country they're just cutting them loose
we speak with gop senator james lankford
i'm jessica rosenthal what did officials
know about the origins of kovid and did
that change rather quickly at the
beginning of the pandemic you know you
were not saying that this research
caused covet but we are saying that it's
very suspicious that there was this
effort to get around one narrative
quickly we talked to fox news special
report anchor bret baer and i'm david
marcus
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
it's been this way for more than a year
migrants surging to the u.s and it's a
strain on agents and our southern border
the role that border patrol agents play
in
ensuring security and safety at our
borders is something that there's great
value for in this administration white
house press secretary jen saki but even
the u.s border patrol chief raul ortiz
admits morale is at an all-time low and
he got an earful from agents in a video
shared with fox by a border patrol
source we continue to do the job in the
mission that we signed up for
all right we all signed up or we all
ready for hand
it's kind of hard to say that to defend
the constitution it's not hard to say
for evil the triumph is for good men to
do nothing that's exactly what's
happening here good men are doing
nothing you're allowing illegally
a republican senator who wanted to see
what's going on for himself went to the
border over the weekend there's an
ongoing chaos that the american people
are not seeing on the southern border
that you really don't see real reporting
on in the depth of it until you actually
can lay eyes on it to be able to see it
gop senator james langford from oklahoma
went down to texas we have two million
people that have illegally crossed the
border that we've interdicted just last
calendar year two million people and
when i talked to the border patrol about
saying those are the people that you
caught how many people what they call
got aways that they actually identified
and said they're over there but we just
don't have the manpower to get to them
but they know that they're there and
they're moving
but they didn't catch them and they said
that number is up 90 percent from last
year 90 percent 90. so there's a
tremendous there's a tremendous number
of people that are crossing the border
illegally that we never interdict okay
and so when you say that's up 90 are we
talking about the same
two million type figure we're talking
hundreds of thousands how many are they
the great unknown at that point uh so
they they can only document what they
have seen uh on the in the bush or what
they've seen somewhere else and picked
up and said okay that's a group moving i
see seven moving right there and they
can't get to them and they get away okay
so they turn in that figure to be able
to figure okay we we we caught this many
but we also had this many we weren't
able to catch
and uh that number continues to climb as
well that frustration that we've seen in
these videos did you get that when you
talk to people too well it's very real
it's very palpable these are law
enforcement professionals many of them
that have served 10 20 30 years on the
line actually protecting the nation and
if they're sent out at night we're
talking 2 a.m
going through heavy brush interdicting
someone that they they are aware that
there's someone there they don't know if
that's a family group coming through
they don't know if that's a cartel
member moving drugs it's or that's
heavily armed they have no idea who
they're going and interdict they're
literally risking their lives to go
interdict people and then the bite
administration's just cutting them loose
once they've been interdicted it's
exceptionally frustrating for law
enforcement saying why am i putting my
life on the line every day to be able to
do this when everybody's just being
allowed to be able to come into the
country they're just cutting them loose
and part of the conversation that i
heard in what's called the muster the
gathering of all the
border patrol before they actually leave
out for the evening uh was nicaraguans
in venezuelans now if they're adult
males from nicaragua
or venezuela they're just being released
into the country uh they're not even
attempting to be able to actually deport
those individuals in fact
the night that i was there just the
night before they had interdicted five
syrian males that they had actually
interdicted and one of the guys had
picked up a member of the nicaraguan
military who had told him he was a part
of the military but he'd already been
cut loose into the country they were
still questioning the syrians there but
the member of the nicaraguan military
they had already released into the
country we have no idea where he is now
there were some other videos that also
caused a stir one shows a plane at
westchester county new york airport
after landing in the middle of the night
with migrants on board we don't really
know anything we're in charge of
security
so that's that's where we're having a
problem it's two security contractors
talking in footage obtained via a
freedom of information act request by
former westchester county executive rob
astorino
what's the big secret everybody knows
it's happening
[Music]
kind of hard to hear he says betraying
the american people by the government
now the white house says that's not new
war news it was a flight in august of
unaccompanied minors on their way to
sponsor homes now the other video shows
adult males being bussed out of
brownsville texas and into the interior
u.s yep that's still that's still
happening right now in fact i went to an
area called la plaza which is a parking
garage in brownsville actually went to
that location to be able to see it and
they're set up full-on where they're
having border patrol they're like drop
people off there ice is processing them
there in that parking garage putting
them on buses and taking them out either
at airports or putting them on long-term
buses to be able to ship them around the
country that's happening right now
especially with venezuelans and
nicaraguans but again the white house
had said that they were not letting
adult males into the country for the
most part so there's a disconnect here
there's a big disconnect and that's
again why border patrol was so angry at
this muster to say what's going on you
know we're we're actually doing this
interdiction and you're just cutting
them loose why is it stopping now the
white house will say well if they're
from mexico we're turning them around
immediately but just this year so far
they've already picked up people from 60
different countries just this year these
are people coming from all over the
world because they know the borders open
and if they cross it they're going to
get in let me play you what president
biden said on monday when asked about
the border situation there's a whole lot
of illegal
movement but
there's also a way to begin to deal with
the reason they're leaving in the first
place once again root causes a big issue
in the white house and the president had
already tasked vice president harris
with with trying to figure this issue
out where are we on that so there's two
painful realities here one is the
president seems to miss we live in the
greatest country on god's earth
everyone in the world wants to come to
the united states so it's not like this
is new uh he's quote-unquote dealt with
root causes when he was eight years as
vice president uh never dealt with it at
all then and kamala harris is certainly
not dealing with this so that's a great
press line that they can throw out there
saying that we're going to try to deal
with root causes but when you're the
greatest country on earth the draw is
who we are
when you were down there did you get to
areas where there was
wall construction going on i did
actually so that there's another thing
the big administration saying we have
pushed them for a solid year to say they
stopped wall construction that area left
these huge gaps in the wall where there
would be 20 40 60 feet sometimes a
couple of miles where the wall was
actually in process of being constructed
and they just stopped it on january the
20th 2021 so they've now said well we've
restarted we're closing those gaps but
if you go and look at the fencing that
they're putting up it's like a little
picket fence that you could step over
that's the closing the gaps in that area
they call it a guard rail
it's not a wall and where you see uh
where the the trump wall was up there
before it was 30 feet tall with the
anti-climb everything on the top of it
now it's a short little stubby what i
call the precious little wall uh that's
there in between it it's a waste of
money what about the families that have
come over that are being held or
detained what's happening with them
families are all being released still if
they come over with a child or if they
come over as a family unit they're 100
all being released into the country
if they're a single adult male it's not
from mexico the vast majority of those
are being released into the country and
there's all this conversation about well
they've got to get a covet vaccine and
covet testing that that's actually not
true there's a testing that's required
now but they're not required to have the
vaccine so while the white house is
trying to impose on federal workers and
members of the military and private
employers of vaccine mandate they don't
have a vaccine mandate for people
illegally crossing the border are they
tested they are tested that was not true
a year ago when i was there or months
ago when i was there they have shifted
that now they are tested but they no
longer
they don't have a vaccine mandate they
offer them a vaccine if they say no they
say okay and they allow them to come
into country i wish federal workers and
members of our military and private
employers had the same rights that
people that illegally across our border
have dealing with the vaccine when they
are allowed into the u.s
they are supposed to have a hearing
right for their status at some point in
the future that is correct so there they
illegally cross the border they're
released into it they're giving
documentation saying in this city at
this time show up for a hearing to deal
with your status that hearing time now
is six years in the future
six six years
six years in the future so they are
illegally present in our country for six
years until they actually have their
first hearing
to be able to determine whether they're
allowed to be able to stay if they don't
show up for that hearing no one's going
to come looking for them and it's been
very clear from talking with homeland
security and asking are you pursuing
people that haven't shown up for
hearings in the past the answer is no
they're saying no we're those aren't
priorities for us they list them as a
priority but they're not actually going
after those individuals that are not
showing up for hearings and everyone
knows it and so that what it creates is
is this rolling cycle where people cross
the border illegally from whatever
country they're in they then text family
members back home and say i got across
here's what i said here's what i did
here's where i'm living now come join me
and the next family member actually
comes across and they do it the exact
same way and more people are coming
have you had any
conversations with the biden
administration or with the even
secretary mayorkas where you were you
can find some common ground on some of
these things
absolutely yeah
keeping very open conversation just met
with some of the leadership of homeland
security yesterday after being down
there all this weekend they came in my
office yesterday we walked through some
of these issues they give me this
company line of we're doing our best
we're trying uh we're making amends
we're working with mexico and trying to
be able to manage all this but they're
not putting any leverage on mexico
they're not they're not pushing mexico
to enforce their southern border or
their northern border they're allowing
cartels to be able to run their northern
border and mexico is now saying well we
don't want these folks brought back to
our country once they cross your border
we don't want them back and the bight
administration is doing no pressure on
mexico to actually take these
individuals back other than the mexicans
coming through if somebody said senator
fix this what would you do uh there's
there are very straightforward ways to
be able to fix this one is the asylum
process if we we don't change the asylum
process
other than if people want to apply for
asylum they've got to remain right there
at the border to be able to go through
their processing they're not actually
allowed into the country you start by
saying whoever came in most recently
their hearing is up first so it's not a
matter of waiting six years for a
hearing your hearing is going to be next
week and we go through the process most
people that apply for asylum don't
qualify for asylum asylum means i can't
go anywhere safely in my country most
people are coming because they've got a
job offer from somebody in the united
states or a relative in the united
states and they're coming to join them
that's not asylum and so those
individuals will be turned away that
would immediately send the message back
hey you can't get into america anymore
and they would start texting their
family members saying don't come it was
a waste of time and money to be able to
come because it's not working anymore
that's significant we've got to finish
the infrastructure with real
infrastructure it's one of the things
border patrol wants is to say we we can
better patrol if we can identify where
people are going to move and we're
limiting their access to infrastructure
and then the next big issue is they've
got to have the personnel to actually do
it and policy people that are going to
back it up it can be enforced the trump
administration showed it can be enforced
there's just no will to enforce it
anymore well the divide administration
says that that it was inhumane the trump
policy was inhumane and and they didn't
want people to come here
in one migrant didn't want immigrants
together amazed me they always bring up
there were three weeks time period they
did what they were calling separating
families you can argue about it one way
or the other but that only happened
three weeks the rest of the time they
were enforcing the law consistently and
it made an enormous difference in the
number of people illegally crossing our
border senator james lankford republican
from oklahoma back from the border thank
you very much for joining us
you bet glad to be able to join you
[Music]
this is david marcus with your fox news
commentary coming up
last week fox news special report anchor
bret baer produced a lengthy deep dive
look at the origins of covid from the
perspective of what officials had been
saying privately in the early days of
the pandemic special report obtained
internal documents from the national
institutes of health showing dr anthony
fauci the head of the national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases is
warned kovid may have come from a lab in
china the wuhan institute of virology on
january 27 2020 he's told that niaid has
been indirectly funding the lab through
money given to eco health alliance a
us-based nonprofit that does work on
novel coronaviruses
after immunology professor at scripps
research dr christian anderson tells dr
fauci that the virus looks engineered on
january 30th fauci holds a conference
call with colleagues his deputy doctor
hugh auchenklaus informs fauci later
that day auctioncloth confirms a study
into experiments with the novel
coronavirus funded through the niaid
may not have gone through proper
biosafety review and oversight he tells
fouchy their staff will quote try to
determine if we have any distant ties to
this work abroad fauchi then has a
conference call with virologists from
around the world that call included dr
mike farzan who asked how much could be
in nature accidental release or natural
event i'm 70 30 or 60 40. another
scientist dr robert gary from tulane
university said he couldn't think of a
plausible natural scenario where you get
from a bat virus to ncov covet i just
can't figure out how this gets
accomplished in nature of course in the
lab it would be easy to generate the
perfect 12 base insert that you wanted
on that call fauci and nih head dr
francis collins are told about prior
state department warnings regarding lack
safety protocols inside the wuhan lab
colin says after all this he believes a
natural origin is more likely but a
convening of experts in a confidence
inspiring framework is needed or the
voices of conspiracy will quickly
dominate
shortly after this work published by
some of the scientists on that call
abandons the suspicion that the virus
may have come from a lab but in april of
2020 bear aired a report based on
sources in which he says suspicions
remain covid started in a lab the next
day april 16th they frustrated collins
emails fauchi wondering if there's
something nih can do to help put down
this very destructive conspiracy colin's
email includes a link to our special
report and foxnews.com reporting a day
later fauci replies quote i would not do
anything about this right now it is a
shiny object that will go away in times
doctors anderson gary who'd expressed
concern that this started in a lab but
later reversed themselves in published
works won a nearly nine million dollar
research grant from dr fauci's agency
and peter dazek of ecohealth alliance
got a seven and a half million dollar
grant
while doctors collins and fauci have
since then said they are open to the
possibility that kovit came from a lab
they still lean toward it having natural
origins the biggest thing that stands
out is just what was happening privately
versus what was happening publicly on
this issue bret bear is the anchor of
special report and
um it's just really stark you know that
these virologists
are
coming to the likelihood in fact that it
was a it came from a lab the wuhan lab
and
you know one goes as far as saying i
think it's 70 30.
others are saying i just don't see how
it's evolutionary in its formation
and yet
after this conference call and this back
and forth it gets completely turned
around and
it's it's a conspiracy theory
and it's just
amazing what happens in 48 hours
and that's what struck me most
yeah when you were reading through these
emails that that your team obtained um
did you what was your sort of own
evolutionary process as you were reading
this were you like
oh my gosh uh here here it is you know
here's exactly what we kind of had been
wondering because you had been you had
sources back early in the pandemic that
were telling you that the lab leak
theory was possible were you thinking
this is very validating but also
troubling
yes because you know after we did our
report in march of 2020
we were called conspiracy theorists and
um you know people in the media said
this is way out there um so yeah it is a
bit validating we don't know
definitively obviously because the
chinese haven't opened the doors
and we don't know definitively
why this effort was made to
not talk about what was being talked
about privately but you can make some
circumstantial judgments
about that and
you know possibly one of them and this
is what senator rand paul talks about is
the u.s funding of
gain of function research at that lab
and maybe that's one of the reasons why
they didn't want to talk about this
you had said in the report that eco
health alliance was the third party
right that had received funding from
nih and had
been doing work at
wuhan
what what did you
what did you learn about
peter danzig and eco health alliance um
i know you shared in the report but was
there any
more to that should there be
more to that because the definition of
gain of function
was was also changed right on on uh
government websites after all
it was
and i think that's all part of it um you
know game of functions essentially
altering
the virus to make it more
a threat and then the purpose of it is
to come up with vaccines
that
can solve that
but
there's a couple of things here one is
that this particular project through eco
health was funded by the u.s
then the obama administration put a stop
to all gain of function research a pause
however this particular
group eco health was
bypassed that pause and continued their
work
in wuhan and were it was signed off by
nih
so
that continued and
while the definition on the website
changed it didn't look like what they
were doing changed
and add to that
real concerns about the safety protocols
and the
procedures at wuhan that were noted by
the state department and multiple wires
um and cables and i i think
you add that together and you know you
were not saying that this research
caused covet but we are saying that it's
very suspicious that there was this
effort to get around one narrative
quickly
um back to the part where um you had
said early in the pandemic that you had
sources that were saying you know the
truth will come out eventually about
what's going on and if it really is um
you know maybe possibly from a lab but
that there was concern at the time
and i think you said it because a lot of
our stuff a lot of our ppe even personal
protective gears made in china what is
your sense now about
why officials didn't want to
go down that road after all of this and
and you you addressed it but is it just
that fear of being linked of being
connected in some way to the wuhan lab
that's the why that we don't know
definitively
but
you know and that testimony is what
republicans on oversight judiciary want
to want to get to
i think
in some of those emails francis collins
head of nih says
that for the good of science and the
good of science in china in particular
um
it's important
to get on the same page is essentially
what he writes and
i i'm guessing that that interaction
plays into it but that why
is a big part of the next step in this
story were you surprised um not only
that the lab league theory was tagged
with information warnings on social
media but that
now that it's a much more accepted
possibility and that skepticism has
reversed
so quickly
yeah i think it has turned completely
there are some neurologists who are very
aggressive now and believe
there's no way
that this level of
a virus being contagious
and jumping like it has
could be from nature from animal to
animal to human
um there are some like dr redfield
former head of the cbc who
are convinced um others are not sure and
the real question is whether we're ever
going to know because the chinese have
erased documents they've
dumped data
there are some scientists who are
missing
um
and
you know we have we still have not had
access
to wuhan bret many including myself have
been following joe rogan and i listened
to some of his podcasts um as have
millions of others that are being called
misinformation
with certain doctors
and
while many are now calling for spotify
to dump rogan and sort of end our
ability to hear these conversations
someone tweeted this and i want to share
it with you
they don't think they're spreading
misinformation they think they have a
valid point they may be wrong but that's
different instead of accusing them of
lying explain why facts say otherwise
given that the idea
that the lab leak theory was once
considered misinformation and a
conspiracy
and what is deemed misinformation can
change
how important is it to
have these conversations to question
well it's really important and and we
should never be in the position of
canceling anybody's right to question
even if it's controversial it should be
uh it should be welcomed uh you know
debate facts finding you know he's right
joe rogan when he responded to that
controversy when he said you know it
used to be
uh you get cancelled or
erased from social media if you said
that the possibility of a wuhan lab leak
happened or
that
if you have the vaccine you can still
catch
covet you know if you said that
you were erased from twitter or facebook
and
you know it's looking more and more
likely that it may have come from that
lab
and definitively you can catch covet
even if you're triple vaccinated
unfortunately sadly brad finally what
has happened since your piece aired
exploring the coveted origin story i i
think we saw benjamin hall this week
with a report from more scientists
speaking up but has anybody specifically
reached out to you or your team um to
further validate this reporting or to
react to it in any way
we had multiple uh people on i mentioned
redfield
we had jim jordan on who
his committee uh
congressman he's the ranking member at
oversight is trying to go down this road
but obviously they're not in the
majority and so they don't have the
power to call the a committee hearing
but they've had um
some
some people testify and uh it sounds
like they're going to continue that
effort and especially if they get the
majority i don't think this is going
away people who say
what's the purpose you know why do this
you know the origins of this are
important to find out
no matter how we do
one more finally brett um you said that
you had shared the the piece uh it was a
lengthy piece of more than 11 minutes um
with dr fauci's office and you hadn't
heard back last week have you since
heard from anyone at nih or from dr
fauci's office or anyone with those with
those offices with national institutes
no
no no and we provided the peace we
provided the different emails we had a
list of questions
um that have not been answered and he's
going around the edges i've other people
have interviewed him and asked something
along those lines and he continues to
say
it's most likely in his mind that it was
natural but it's possible now which is
opening the door uh which he wasn't at
the beginning and uh but we haven't had
a specific response to the uh to the
piece
bret bear thank you so much for your
time and for the work thanks
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa rate and review the fox
news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen it's time for your
fox news commentary
david marcus
what's on your mind truckers are a
unique breed there are very few jobs in
modern western life quite so solitary as
driving a huge vehicle across the mostly
barren landscapes of north america
miles of road are coursed under heavy
tires and light thoughtful mines free to
linger on their own devices
so the anti-vaccine mandate protest
initiated by these modern day cowboys in
canada is worth paying attention to
these are people who know a thing or two
about freedom in fact they base their
whole life around it what is most
telling about the reaction to the
protest is the disdain being shown to
these truckers by their own government
and many in the media prime minister
justin trudeau has dismissed the effort
and apparently gone into hiding as the
big rigs surround the capital of ottawa
he claims that these men and women hold
unacceptable views
heaven forbid
you see for politicians like trudeau and
so many leftists in canada and the
united states it's not really covet they
are worried about it's the idea that
some people specifically people who work
for a living and aren't slaves to their
handouts have the audacity not only to
disagree with them but also to ignore
them
pandemic restrictions and mandates
galore are easy to impose on urban
dwellers with office and service jobs
they can be and have been crushed with
the flick of a governor's pen
but denizens of the open road without
whom our modern miracle have been
existent screeches to a hungry
standstill are not so easy to control
most of us in the influencer class the
politicians and pundits leaders of
business and those unsung heroes
hollywood celebrities don't think very
much about how things actually get done
toilets flush thanks to plumbers houses
are built thanks to carpenters and yes
stores shelves are stocked at least they
used to be thanks to truckers the better
sort of people with their degrees and
acceptable views don't generally have to
think much about any of this
but what the canadian truck protest
shows is that this is a two-way highway
the truckers are just as free to ignore
the elites as the elites are to ignore
the truckers the key difference being
that the elites don't produce much
beyond noisy chatter over the past week
it has been noticed that the very
influencers and outlets who have spent
two years lecturing in favor of
lockdowns have come to a now it can be
said moment maybe kids shouldn't be
wearing masks at school the new york
times and the atlantic suddenly opine
perhaps there is nuance we now hear from
the buttery voices of npr
part of this is because lockdowns have
led to embarrassingly bad poll numbers
for the favorite party of the elite but
there is something deeper there is an
emerging recognition that regular people
the ones who actually do things and make
society function are under no obligation
to listen to the bleedings of the
supposedly powerful
maybe freedom isn't dead after all
the time may be coming when robots push
hogs across the vast stretches of north
america when we no longer need the
obstinate caffeinated men and women
counting mile markers with empty packs
of cigarettes but that time ain't yet
for now with the turn of a key they can
threaten those who seek to control them
it's a valuable lesson
when those who choose to live a solitary
existence who wish power over no one but
themselves decide to speak out it's
worth listening and if the politicians
listen carefully they will learn
something important they work for the
truckers the truckers do not work for
them
this is david marcus author of charade
the coveted lies that crushed a nation
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes